there's been a video released as just  some breaking news about is and the is  have threatened to kill two Japanese  hostages and s a very large ransom is  paid they're looking for two hundred  million dollars and they want that in 72  hours and the the video shows the  Islamic state threatening to kill two  Japanese hostages and and they reckon  that the man speaking it says resembled  and signed it like the British militant  involved in other beheadings the guy  who's come to be known as jihadi John  and and the two hostages are in orange  jumpsuits and they say that Japan has  proudly donated 100 million dollars to  kill our women and children to destroy  the homes of Muslims and this is what  this revenge is a bite will keep you  posted on this is about